[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to the stage the
Honorable David Marr mayor of the city
of Cambridge welcome there and I'm
equally delighted to welcome to these
exercises the distinguished members of
our 50th reunion class the great class
of 1960 it's now my honor to introduce
our commencement speaker brace Stata
class of 1957 gray received his SB and
SM degrees in electrical engineering
from MIT a pioneer in the semiconductor
industry gray co-founded analog devices
in 1965 his entrepreneurial spirit
thrived and he went on to found state of
venture partners to provide venture
capitals to other tech startups he was
also instrumental in the founding of the
mass hi-tech council because it's events
have earned him numerous recognitions
remember the National Academy of
Engineering the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences a recipient of the I Triple
E founders medal and many honorary
degrees but perhaps a man like Ray is
best measured by those qualities
instilled in him in Pennsylvania where
he grew up integrity trust honesty and a
strong work ethic core strengths that
define his life and enabled his success
Ray's passion may very well be centered
in engineering and entrepreneurship but
he's always been committed to his alma
mater and to strengthening this
community since his election to the MIT
corporation in 1984 ray has served as
one of its strongest leaders he and his
wife Maria have been enormous ly
important not only in helping to build
mi t--'s infrastructure just in case you
recognize the name at the Stata Center
but also in building education
excellence at MIT we are deeply grateful
for their deep and continuing commitment
to MIT so ladies and gentlemen
distinguished guests graduates and
graduates to be may I present race data
Thank You Dana and good morning everyone
and congratulations you should be
brimming with pride this morning
you have earned a degree from the
world's most prestigious university
focused on science and engineering you
have mastered mi t--'s unique brand of
learning and doing which will
distinguish you throughout your career
and congratulations as well to your
friends and family who supported you and
encouraged you along the way your
satisfaction and happiness in life
depend on the choices you make and on
the principles and values which guide
them so far your choices have served you
extremely well as a fellow nerd I'm
honored to share with you some of my
experiences and some of the principles
and values which have worked well for me
as MIT graduates we are all innovators
and entrepreneurs at heart we search for
opportunities to do things better to
make things happen
and to change the world in my case I
also had a strong desire to be in
control by destiny so to satisfy this
need I aspired to someday start my own
company with this end in mind shortly
after graduation I went to work for
hewlett-packard hewlett-packard for me
was like a mini MBA where I learned the
basics of business but more importantly
I learned from hewlett-packard that
commitment to the welfare of employees
and to the development of their full
potential
are the cornerstones on which successful
companies are built you sometimes don't
know where the PS you take will lead
when I was about 27 one day on Harvard
Square I bumped into Matthew Larbre an
acquaintance from my students days that
was looking for a roommate so we ended
up not only sharing an apartment
but also three years later we together
co-founded analog devices of course we
had no idea that analog devices would
become a multi-billion dollar company
and a leader in an important segment of
the semiconductor industry we started by
carving out a small niche and then step
by step we extended our core
competencies and built on our success
analogs business strategy focused on
opportunities where we could achieve and
sustain leadership our mantra was market
leadership through technical innovation
being number one not only produces
superior business results
it also engenders a sense of pride and
satisfaction and stimulates your
competitive instincts to stay ahead so
don't ever give up on your ambition to
be the best at whatever you do it's more
rewarding and it's also more fun we
quickly discovered that you can't be an
innovative company unless you have great
innovators
so at analog rather than sidetracking
our best engineers into management we
created a parallel ladder to encourage
them to continue their technical careers
we not only provided compensation that
was comparable to the management track
but we also gave engineers a voice in
influencing business strategy investment
decisions organizational policies I
encouraged managers to treat engineers
as full business partners the highest
rung on our technical ladder was
reserved for our most distinguished
engineers who we call analog devices
fellows fellows at analog are important
people whose views are respected in
value
don't let organizational hierarchy
obscure the people who are most
important to your success another
important way to unlock innovation is to
free people to do their best work
in building the organization I found
that a lot of talented people were just
like me they wanted the freedom to
decide what to do and how to do it so I
shaped a culture which gave employees
broad latitude to make decisions we
didn't have a lot of rules and controls
we'd have we depended more on developing
people's judgment we aligned the goals
of the company and the goals of
employees and we encouraged employees to
think about the company's success as a
prerequisite to their own empowering
people to make decisions and to take
ownership is a powerful motivator this
was a key factor in our success in
effect we built our market position on a
culture of innovation but then the
question becomes how do you maintain
your lead Andy Grove the former CEO of
Intel wrote a book in which he
proclaimed only the paranoid survive
beware of s-curves because everything
has life cycles technologies products
markets and companies to sustain
innovation you can't abandon your
appetite for risk when analog devices
started linear linear integrated
circuits or so-called ICS had not yet
been invented we manufactured our
operational amplifiers and converters by
manually assembling discrete transistors
and other components on printed circuit
boards just two years after we opened
our doors the industry's first
integrated circuit operational
amplifiers were introduced our hand
tweaked amplifiers consistently
outperformed these new devices but each
year they got better and they were an
order of magnitude cheaper so I
concluded that to avoid becoming a
victim of our own s-curve we had to take
bold steps to learn how to design and
manufacture ICS or our success would be
short-lived everyone and I mean everyone
in the company disagreed they said that
integrated circuits would never meet the
one's requirements of our customers that
we shouldn't risk a rapidly growing and
very profitable business that we didn't
have the financial resources to compete
with a large semiconductor companies and
beside that nobody in the company knew
anything about semiconductor technology
so the board said no it was too risky
for me the the risk of inaction was even
greater so I made an offer the board
couldn't refuse
I offered to personally fund a startup
company to design and manufacture ICS
which in Alor would sell and if this
venture succeeded analog would have the
option to acquire this company with no
gain for my investment on the other hand
that if it's if it failed I would
personally suffer the loss now a lot of
people thought I was very foolish but it
worked
three years later analog acquired the
startup and got serious about
semiconductor technology we figured out
ways to manufacture ICS that achieve
performance even better and that our
hand-assembled products and at a
fraction of the cost this breakthrough
innovation established analog devices as
a leader in high-performance linear
integrated circuits a position we still
hold today
the point is entrepreneurs have to be
optimistic and relentless in believing
that they will discover or create the
missing pieces even when they're not
sure how courage and the capacity take
to take risk or fundamental to
entrepreneurship if you're not stepping
outside your comfort zone to take
calculated risks chances are you will
not be exploiting your full potential
you can't play it safe and win don't be
afraid to fail or make mistakes chances
are you'll do this many times and
failure is not always bad in fact people
don't really learn by doing things right
they learn by making mistakes and then
reflecting on what
wrong my wife Maria says that I'm
frequently wrong but never in doubt now
I'm not too sure about the frequently
part but for sure I've made my share of
mistakes perhaps my biggest failure was
analog devices enterprises an investment
a venture investment fund that I set up
within the company nothing came of it we
lost a lot of money and the mistake I
made was to allow our investments to
stray too far from analogs core
competencies in the delicate balance
between focus and diversification I
stepped over the line I certainly
learned a lot from that experience
but if success for an entrepreneur
depends on cultivating perpetual
innovation it also depends on how you
work with others how much you demand of
yourself and how much you believe in
what you're doing for most of you your
accomplishments will be magnified by
productive collaborations and by your
ability to lead teams and organizations
to those ends
I found you could be most effective by
building trustful relationships you earn
trust through honesty adhering to the
facts integrity living by principles
sincerity meaning what you say
reliability meeting your commitments and
competence knowing what you're doing as
high achievers in the real world you
will soon discover as I did that you
can't substitute working smarter for
working harder to excel at the top of
your game you have to do both so be
prepared to continue to drink for the
from the fire hose as a way of life the
most important advice I can give you is
this if ever you find that you are not
passionate and excited about what you're
doing then start searching for an
opportunity where you will be nothing is
more important and gratifying than
getting up in the morning with an
eagerness to get to work and accomplish
something important set high standards
for what you expect from your work be
courageous in stepping into the unknown
and think big about what you can
accomplish if history's any good guide
as MIT graduates 40% of you will have
played an important role in an
early-stage startup venture by the time
you reach age 45
a recent Sloan School study reported
that cumulative the league a hundred and
twenty-two thousand living MIT graduates
have founded more than 25 thousand
companies which are still in business
today and which collectively generate
two trillion dollars in sales and employ
3.3 million people and this does not
include the companies that were acquired
the fact is that the spirit of
innovation and entrepreneurship applies
not just a business engineering and
science but to every aspect of work and
life you are all well equipped to
challenge the status quo and to bring
about dramatic changes and improvements
in whatever you choose to do and you
will also find opportunities as to as
volunteers to apply your knowledge and
skills to solve important societal
problems from my involvement in K
through 12 education
I found that public institutions are the
ones most in need of intervention from
iconoclast like us to engineer
desperately needed change in
improvements mit has played a very
important role in my life as a hayseed
from a small farm community I was the
first in my family to attend college
without MIT s need-blind admissions I
would have not had access to the
Institute's unique education experience
as soon as we could afford it
marina I made a gift to not only repay
MIT for the significant investment it
made in me but also to repay a debt of
gratitude for what MIT had enabled me to
do in my career beyond what I had gained
personally as I became more involved I
better understood in mi t--'s enormous
impact on the world an impact that I'm
convinced will become even more
important in this complicated century
with its unmatched depth and breadth of
research and its culture of
interdisciplinary collaboration mit is
uniquely positioned to tackle the
world's biggest problems energy
environmental sustainability poverty
human disease just the name of the few
Maria and I believe so strongly in mi
STIs mission and in the in the people of
MIT that we've actively looked for ways
to help MIT do what it does best for
example as a member of the electrical
engineering and computer science
visiting committee I learned that there
was an urgent need to better integrate
these disciplines by relocating the
computer science and side of the
department from across the tracks in
tech square to campus so Marie and I
offered to make a lead gift to catalyze
this important decision initially
initially the new facility was conceived
as just another box on Vassar Street the
once started the imagination of the
faculty and Institute leaders were
unleashed and the project took on a
bolder vision than just a new home for
computer science it quickly became an
inspiring space for students and faculty
from across the campus to play to hang
out to eat to exercise and even dance a
place to facilitate human interaction
and to terminate new ideas the center
stands today as a constant reminder that
MIT is about breaking with tradition and
exploring new frontiers there are many
many examples large and small where MIT
graduates got involved Sol indeed and
became part of the solution so I urge
you to stay involved with MIT for search
for and to search for ways where you can
make a difference and when your time
comes to give back like its peer
universities MIT very much depends on
the work of the wisdom and the wealth of
the spirit of its graduates to sustain
its greatness
and equally important as products of MIT
education it is through your
accomplishments that mi t--'s
contribution to society are amplified
you are entering a trouble
that is both in crisis and in transition
in crisis due to the lapse of judgment
and moral values of business and
political leaders which triggered a deep
and far-reaching financial meltdown in
transition due to China Russia and India
ending decades of isolation and
releasing three billion people into the
free market economy coping with the
stresses on financial and natural
resources from an aging and growing
global population with increasing
expectations for a better life presents
seemingly insurmountable challenges but
when I reflect on the ingenuity of the
human race and on the truly amazing
things which have been accomplished just
in my lifetime I'm optimistic that your
generation will not only find solutions
to today's challenges but you will also
discover new opportunities for progress
in a more integrated and inclusive world
remember as MIT graduates you are the
best the world has to offer with
technology playing an ever-increasing
role you have a special responsibility
to help create a future where every
person on this planet can have the hope
and the prospects for a better life so
my charge to you this morning is don't
play it safe because the risk of
inaction is just too great dare to be
part of the solution thank you and best
wishes for a happy life
you